clair vous restez en plateau on continue
cette chronique de l'cho la suite c'est
avec l'accord national
interprofessionnel expliqué aux
entrepreneurs du département Laurence
Pariso la patronne du MF éta ce matin à
Saint-Germain on est pour échanger le
texte a beaucoup fait parler certains
syndicats de salariés très mécontents
côté patronat on est plutôt
satisfait plus d'un mois et demi après
la signature de l'accord professionnel
de compétitivité Laurence Pariso la
présidente du Medef était aujourd'hui à
Saint-Germain enlet pour débattre du
texte avec les entrepreneurs yvelinois
je vous propose de l'écouter au micro
d'éod moine au fur à mesure que les
patrons de TPE de PME ou d'entreprise
même de de taille plus importante le
découvre ils réalisent qu'effectivement
ça leur permettrait de s'adapter plus
rapidement ça leur permettrait de gérer
des situations complexes et au fond ça
offrira une modalité pour pacifier les
relations du travail pour
déconflictualiser sortir des logiques de
contentieux et être beaucoup plus
facilement dans un dialogue constructif
il des
dispositifs vraiment très nouveaux pour
les salariés ils auront désormais
l'accès une complémentaire santé
collective certains en avaient déjà mais
la plupart non ce sera obligatoire dans
les 3 années de mise en œuvre de
l'accord mais il y a encore des étapes à
franchir avant que cet accord n'entre en
œuvre car il faut d'abord qu'il soit
ratifié par le Parlement vous l'avez
compris les entrepreneurs évelinois sont
favorables à ce texte de compétitivité
après une telle négociation Laurence
Parison envisagerait même de se
représenter à sa propre succession en
juillet 2013 à condition que les statuts
du meddef soient changés il faudra
effectivement un changement de statut
puisque seulement deux mandats sont
possibles pour un président une
présidente du meddeef on passe à présent
aux infos en plus et la première
concerne les BRIC colleurs du dimanche
oui le magasin Bricorama situé dans la
zone commerciale d'Orgeval devrait
réouvrir le dimanche le préfet a accepté
de classer le magasin en puce
c'est-à-dire en périmètrre d'usage de
consommation exceptionnelle selon le
président de l'enseigne au total CIN
magasins sont concernés les quatre
traitants dans le valde mararne et on
rappelle que le 4 novembre dernier une
décision de justice avait obligé
Bricorama à fermer le dimanche 32 de ces
boutiques en France et de nombreux
magasins de bricolage HE sont concernés
d'ailleurs sur ces différentes
fermetures le weekend une entreprise qui
embauche dans le secteur de la
mirroiterie oui c'est une bonne nouvelle
cette société de vente et de pose de
menuiserie extérieure recrute au clés
sousbois la mirwaterie a été repris par
Pacotte et Mignotte une entreprise du
même secteur l'année dernière et depuis
la la Miroiterie pardon se porte bien
avec 1,4 million de chiffres d'affaires
en 2012 sont donc recherchés avis aux
intéressés des poseurs des commerciaux
et une assistante commerciale on fait
rebrique de petit petites annonces
d'emploi ce soir dans 7 et puis commerce
toujours si la crise est bel et bien là
les centres commerciaux continuent et
c'est surprenant à prendre de l'ampleur
oui le le parli 2 va s'étendre la
commission nationale d'aménagement
commercial a autorisé donc son son
extension dernièrement la nouvelle
galerie s'appellera ciel de parli elle
va occuper
5313 m Carr de de surface de vente et
les spécialités seront l'alimentaire
l'équipement de la personne l'équipement
de la maison la culture loisir et les
services les chiffres du chômage ne sont
pas bons dans le département la
situation est même plutôt préoccupante
nous faisons le point complet avec
Catherine zulato et puis dans un instant
l'agenda de l'écho pour l'emploi jouer
la transparence visite des locaux de
l'agence de Guill enc ouverte depuis
août 2012 particularité on reçoit les
demandeurs d'emploi non cadres et cadres
une vitrine pour l'institution publique
le taux de chômage atteint ici 5,5 %
similaire à l'Allemagne en 2012 l'agence
guyan courtoise a récolté 5400 offres
essentiellement bon on a le secteur du
commerce he puis avec les centres
commerciaux notamment 50 ans en Eveline
le service à la personne bien sûr et euh
tout ce qui est je dirais informatique
d'accord voilà c'est les trois secteurs
on recrute essentiellement une agence de
Guy en cours donc montrer en exemple 60
agents y sont affectés pourtant les
problématiques de retour à l'emploi sont
les mêmes que partout pour trois types
de population les jeunes les seniors et
les chômeurs de longue durée et les
chiffres qui viennent d'être publiés ce
matin-là pour le département ne sont pas
bons accroissement du nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi dans les lines une
hausse plus rapide qu'au niveau national
plus 2,3 % contre 1 4 % une dégradation
de l'emploi intérimaire qui enregistre
sur un an une baisse de 19,6 % dans les
ivelines contre 12 % pour
l'Île-de-France ça reflète plutôt une
situation de marché de l'emploi et
plutôt moins dynamique qu'il ne l'a
été et donc la conséquence pour les
demandes d'emploi c'est effectivement on
a une croissance de la demande d'emploi
des long de longue durée on a aussi un
point de préoccupation pour lequel on
est parti mobilisé notamment avec la
mise en place des emplois d'avenir sur
la population jeune notamment m les
jeunes non qualifiés qui sont parent
touchés pour la des durées d'accès au
premier emploi ou des situations de
précarité qui sont des des points sur
lequels on est partiement attentif et on
est partiement mobilisé avec les équipes
les ivelines restent toutefois un
département encore épargné avec un taux
global de chômage qui s'élève à 7 % à
comparé au 10,5 % au plan national le
département dans sa partie nord en
vallée de Scine souffre notamment de
baisse d'emploi dans l'industrie
automobile et pour conclure cette
chronique de l'cho comme à chaque fois
l'agenda à Noé donc un atelier sur le
télétravail pour ceux qui seraient
intéressés par ce mode de travail ou qui
souhaiteraient l'installer dans leur
société ça se passe à la Cité des
Métiers à trrape le 5 mars et puis une
autre journée d'information sur la
création d'entreprise cette fois pour
ceux qui seraiit tenté de se lancer dans
l'aventure c'est organisé à la Maison de
l'Entreprise de Rambouillet le 14 mars
merci Claire on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau point sur
l'économie merci à nos invités aussi qui
sont restés en plateau pendant la fin de
cette chronique on va tester les bonbons
hein vous sauvez pas rester avec vos
bonbons conf fis box c'est la fin du 78
demain même horaire vous retrouverez
Catherine zulato pour l'édition du
weekend pour faire un point complet sur
ce qu'il faut retenir de cette semaine
d'actualité dans le département je vous
souhaite une excellente
[Musique]
soirée